US, we approach the episode of, uh,
Camacho's wedding.
Uh,
it should be readily apparent,
uh,
that it was the story of
what's going to be a play.
Uh, it has a beginning, a conflict
or climax and a resolution,
uh,
given that it has a happy ending,
uh, it's safe to assume that
it was going to be a comedy.
Actually, scholars of Ferritin
around undiscovered, uh,
evidence that indeed it was a play
that Cervantes was planning to write,
uh,
and a set of antigens seems
founding the Quixote, uh,
a book where he could a total
dump all of his work in progress.
The, uh, the stories, uh, uh,
some of which wound up of course
it the book a exemplary stories.
But some of the, uh, the stories in
the book of course where, uh, uh,
written independently on her
actually circulated independently,
uh,
the novel as it's being developed in the
cohort that will be a uninclusive kind
of, uh, of, uh, of literary work, uh,
with a loose format,
uh,
not following the strict
rules of our literary forms.
Or John has a derived from
the classical tradition where,
uh, these, uh, liberties, uh,
who are not available but
the Quixote does, uh, allow,
uh,
for these kinds of incorporation
of stories and have various texts.
It is a, uh, a feature that the novel, uh,
we'll continue to have. And that in the
modern period of course, uh, will be,
uh, exploited to the, to the very limits.
Um,
lenders also notice how these love story
is a neatly integrated into the plot of
the novel as opposed to the
more than general way in which,
uh,
such stories were inserted in part to uh,
here,
uh,
donkey hope they central are more or
less involved in the developments and
certainly no Quixote's
involved in the outcome.
Of course, given that this was
going to be a play, there is a,
a great deal of theatricality
in the whole episode,
which includes theater within the theater,
uh,
as these celebrations for
the wedding take place.
Even nature has been artistically arranged
so much so that the outdoors now has
a roof.
You may that when they enter the meadow
where the celebration of the wedding is
going to take place.
Uh,
it is noted that the trees have
been arranged in such a way,
uh,
us to provide a canopy a that the sun
can barely penetrate to reach the grass.
Uh, that is his nature
turned into architecture,
us a US adware.
Um,
the play within the play, uh,
is, uh, a way of underlining,
uh, uh, that everything is theatrical,
that there is no real action, uh, uh,
that is not already theater,
that his life is already
theater in part two.
And this is part of the theme of this in
Ganja that I have been underlining for
the past few lectures.
Let us also take notice of the abundance
that prevails here and in the second
part in general,
in contrast with part one,
whereas in, in, in part one,
the characters eight frugally,
uh,
now sent Joe has so much food before
him that he's scarcely knows what to do
with it.
Um,
don't compare this with
the very frugal meal,
that donkey hope they had at that very
first in where he ate a fish because it
was a Friday abundance contrasted
with the starkist want.
It's typical of the aesthetics of
the Baroque, this, uh, this, uh,
clash and a abundance ties,
uh, in with the notion of sensuality, uh,
the sensuality of server antiques art
that Auerbach spoke about in the essay
that you have or red and that he says
he is the hallmark of sort of antithesis
work.
The essential,
the tangible in all its abundance
turns into a simulacrum and reveals its
opposite, which is quite literally
death. This is the, this,
this in Gagnon aspect.
So we have Santos speech about
death being the devour of all,
as I said,
the overarching plot and
the plot within the, uh,
the work in this,
uh,
stories follows this pattern of in Ganja,
Ganja.
Now we may ask when we come to this
episode of why our wedding so important in
fiction, including film of course
in the theater too, but him film,
there are many, uh,
films that you, uh, uh,
I'm sure I can remember, uh,
that uh, center on a wedding,
weddings mark a moment of Social Union
and renewal both of society and of our
Matrix.
They are at transition mark by 15,
particularly by eating in fiction.
Weddings tend to be conclusions.
Uh,
they married and lived
happily ever after is common,
uh,
traditional ending two stories in the,
in the, in the wedding celebrations,
the, the world is consumed,
uh,
in a way that leads to the
consummation of, uh, of, of,
of the, of, of the
marriage. Um, the story,
I will see much more about this in a,
in in a very short time,
the story of Camacho's wedding, like
the myth of Pyramus and Thisbe, uh,
which it is based.
You see conjunction of love and death
of arrows and Tinnitus or love that
struggles against death
for continuity and renewal.
There are intimations of
the death scene. Uh, uh,
the culminating death theme, which is
really not the, that scene, but, uh, uh,
contrived or theatrical that scene.
But there are intimations of the death
scene in the calf that is impelled to be
cooked, that our is find as
they arrive at the wedding,
a celebration,
one good one grove.
So see in that impaled calf escape goat,
which is typical of feasts celebrations.
Now Camacho is rich and powerful,
like don't Fernando in part one.
Uh,
what basilio's abilities and skills
prevail over social and economic forces.
His, uh, uh, his, uh,
abilities, uh, win the day.
I'm there as much made of how many
skills he has. He can play the guitar,
he can, uh, he's an athlete.
We later found out that he's
quite an actor also. Uh,
now the, the episode is
a prose a pizza. Lamean
I think I'd better write this.
A poem or song in praise of the bride or
groom or have both from the Greek Epi,
uh,
[inaudible] and [inaudible] chamber
and a,
uh,
a versus a bit alarming is actually
performed as part of the wedding.
A celebration, if you remember
what an elaborate one at that,
uh, this episode of, of, of a wedding, uh,
uh, with such celebrations,
uh, he's, he's,
he's common in the literature
of the period most,
the most prominent one is
in the great poem by Louis.
The gum Guerra, who's name I may not
have mentioned before, who is the great,
uh,
by rock port.
It is from him that you get the
word in English, gum go ristic uh,
something very baroque complicated
and he,
he's famous for many poems,
but the most famous one is
called the solely Dallas.
And uh, in the Solidago
this, there is quite a,
an elaborate wedding, a
ceremony, but it's described
okay.
It is, uh, uh, it's like a spring ritual,
a celebration of nature's replenishment.
Remember the park too vaguely
begins sort of, uh, uh, in spring,
but in the whole episode when wonders
is nature corrected by art or dose,
the nature prevail.
I think the answer is
Opo side art prevails.
That art corrects niche.
And this is again,
one of the main themes in
part to like eat healthy.
Don't you hold these on this side
a of Basilio [inaudible] Camacho.
And in this the episode is very mindful
of Marcella's and resourced almost in
part one when don Quixote,
again, it's on the side of, uh,
of Marcella.
Uh,
perhaps this episode is the,
is the kind of ending that demo say like
resource episode should have had in,
uh, in part one the, uh, the,
the reminiscences of that episode also
in the attempted or faked suicide in part
one resource to us we saw had
actually committed to site.
Now the stories are version of the
myth of Pyramus and Thisbe, uh,
which had been anticipated
by lowering. So, uh,
the Dan does sonnet on the
topic during the episode.
Uh, Diego Demi down does house his
father's house, the man in green,
uh, and it's mentioned directly by
one of the students on the road,
uh, to the, uh, to the wedding.
It is also acted out in the
downside of lava. The spoken dance,
the Peter Lamean during the
wedding festivities. So the,
the myths of period was from Tishbe.
He hangs Haley over this episode.
John Synagis writes,
quote,
the occurrence of the ceremony in a
theater theater like implies that the
wedding is what? One more
active artifice. Therefore,
when Basillio appears,
we become caught up with the spectators,
the wedding,
they let the audience at the play
where to Spencer's Esperando.
They were waiting in suspense to
see what would happen. The heroin,
it star of the play has just stepped
on stage and everyone is anxious to see
what he will do.
Synagogue ads comparing this episode,
which is uh,
uh, the only one on love on, on,
on the second part with the current Daniel
tale of the first part and he writes
the following.
This is a rather lengthy court,
but I think a useful quote from
this, uh, uh, John Finnegan,
it goes,
the final result of the
action of commercials wedding
is the confirmation of the
propriety of romantic love
and the rejection of the
illegitimate claim on love
by greed.
The same conclusion was
provided by Cardinia tail.
There are however important
differences between the two stories.
Cause then you're stale ends in an in to
which the hand of fate had led the two
couples. The Camacho
wedding episode, however,
ends in a stage the conclusion,
the conclusion is brought
about by basileus skill.
The difference between
these two endings reflect,
reflect a significant difference between
part one and part two in part one only
don't be haughty on the priest acted as
authors in the sense that they tried to
impose fiction on reality.
The role of art was of secondary concern
to the other characters in part two.
However,
art and artifice are extremely important
and a larger number of characters from
central bouncer to the Duke
and Duchess and of course, uh,
Samsung Carrasco Act as authors by using
fiction to impose their wills on the,
on all the characters in
connatural wedding Basilea
access author because he is
not content to let fate
decide the end of the story.
Therefore he imposes his will on the other
characters by using fiction to all to
alter the course of the story away
from its natural. And, um, quote,
can you see also what he's also
the act of this play that he has,
uh,
made up.
But another way to look at the episode
is to see it as a modern version of the
beer must anticipate myth,
which is clearly in the ground on a
alumina's have just said over the story.
The Pyramus and Thisbe story in Orbitz
with the morphosis highlights the pagan
theme of suicide,
which Cervantes in his Catholic
environment uses for dramatic effect,
but ultimately avoids. Now, all of it,
we all know who he was and I gave you
some information in the law in the sheet
that I passed around with a copy of
this episode in the metamorphoses.
He was a Roman poet of the,
of the last dog osteon Augustan age.
He's known for his ours.
I'm a Tortilla with someone called the
most immoral work written by amount of
genius.
It's a love.
Don't rush out now to get the book.
Uh,
but the metamorphosis is
his most important work. Uh,
which is a long narrative poem book,
which recounts a legends in which the
miraculous transformations of matter,
uh, occur. In fact,
the poem begins.
My intention is to tell of bodies
changed to different forms.
And it begins with the change
from chaos to customers, uh,
and, uh, and goes on to the moment, uh,
to Julio. Cesar been
transformed into, into a star.
So the Middle Ages took the Vietnam
office is to be kind of a Pagan Bible like
an old testament if you'll test
them and tells the story of the,
uh, of the, of the universe.
So does the metamorphosis using the
classical myths he's influenced,
uh, on, uh, in the
renaissance was a tremendous,
and even in the, in the
late Middle Ages, uh, he,
he was kind of the,
the sourness of myths that artists both,
uh, painters, sculptures and writers, uh,
youth, uh, very often, um,
now, uh, in, in, in Spanish literature,
he was a very influential,
as he was,
of course in English
literature throughout the ages.
Um, he was, he, he, he is,
he with virtual,
uh,
in importance as a classical
author, uh, to be, uh,
followed.
Now they're deeper,
more disturbing aspects
in this story. Uh, uh, uh,
in Cabarrus wording linking
the flat deflowering blot
and the connection between
life and death thing,
to which I will go in some detail.
Love appears as a mock
death to promote life.
Violence and love are complicit because
violence is the subtext of love.
The issue here is of classical
mythologies version of this,
uh, uh, contrasted with, uh,
uh, uh, Christian doctrine.
The question for artists
of the renaissance deeply
interested in the classical
world,
uh,
but living in a Christian one was
what to do with the ancient gods.
Uh,
the most common answer was allegory.
The myths were seeing as moral
allegories. Uh, they, uh,
they told him moral tales.
Um,
but in the case of the
episode of Camacho sweating,
what's the seems to be proposing is a
modern reenactment of an ancient recurring
dilemma concerning love, uh,
and using for that,
the classical myth Pyramus and Thisbe
basilio's arts are used here to steer the
story away from its pagan ending,
uh,
suicide to a victory of
love and Christian marriage.
You have read the story in the handout
that I gave you in the last class.
The Pagan ending is turned into theater.
If the representation into art,
Don Quixote has referred earlier to
marriage as an as an irreparable accident.
It's something that,
you know,
something that sounds very funny to
us today is to just using a scholastic
terminology to refer to it.
I'm always in the context of these
debates about marriage that I will revisit
today.
Basilio makes the accidental,
the result of choice,
his choice.
The point is the skill and wilingness
need to a virtuous result here.
The whole of the second part of
the Quixote is an apology for art,
for the artificial, for the
constructed, for the contrived, for art,
helping nature attained good ends.
After going through the process
of disingenuous that I have been,
uh,
underlining in the past few classes,
it is a way of turning the seat,
which would normally lead to the solution
went into a positive force that leads
to a happy ending.
As I said, by Celia skill
prevail over, uh, uh,
the economic forces,
uh,
the social and economic forces
is his craftiness wins the day.
Now what I claim, uh, is
that is beneath all of that,
the kind of sub story is subtext.
Uh,
this story is a rewriting of the last
stories of part one that turn on on equal
marriage and the that involve
the issue of secret marriages,
which as I said, we're a topic,
uh, the hot topic of the day,
which was taken up by the council of
Trent. I've been read Eliot, you know,
now what the council of Trent was.
I spoke about these issues when, uh, uh,
when speaking about the episode in
which Dorothea allows herself to be
deflowered by Don Fernando.
The difference here is the lurking
precedence of classical myth.
Typical,
more typical of the Baroque in part one.
These stories about all of
this, uh, young people, uh, uh,
seem to be drawn from,
from contemporary legal archives,
contemporary stories about
conflicts involving social issues,
states and legacies.
Here the source is much more imposing.
An ancient,
the myth of period was on therapy,
but true to the political
character of part two. Uh,
there is in addition,
a protracted discussion of the
issue of marriage by the characters.
The issue of marriage was a political
issue, not just a religious issue.
It's impossible to separate the two
other echoes of part one our Basilio's
madness when he hears of credentials,
cutaneous impending marriage,
which recalls both resource
Tamang Cardinia when they go mad.
In the case of Canadian,
mostly we don't see it.
The system will actually act it out.
And of course the issue of suicide, uh,
which evokes, uh, the system. Uh,
this is another case I
emphasize of rewriting episodes
from part one so that we
writings involve here both episodes
in part one on classical myth,
which is being rewritten.
But there is a deeper take on marriage
at the level of material transformations.
The story of commercials.
Wedding is about the issue
of marriage as a sacrament,
the transformation of matter
for transcendental purposes.
That of creating a new human life and
how it is institutionalized in civil and
Canon law.
That is by society and religion.
The law is based on prohibition.
Thou shall not here the ban
instituted by cutaneous parents once,
uh,
she and Basilio have
reached sexual maturity,
which is what quite evident if
you read the story, uh, there, uh,
uh, prevision comes up when they are, uh,
they have reached sexual maturity.
Uh,
she has to be gone to menstruate and
he's now capable of impregnating her.
Her parents are reluctant to have her
reproduce with an input impecunious
Basilio who for all his
skills as not profitable ones,
but that stands also as to simply
the prohibition. Thou shall not,
as we saw when discussing the,
uh, issue, uh, uh, regarding, uh,
Doterra,
a clandestine marriages,
which is lurking here in the background
because we must assume that they had
been one between a Basilio and criteria
that's in marriages could lead to
polygamy.
I mean,
I could say to any girl
that I was involved with,
uh, Jess, yes, I will marry
you. And B, then if the, if,
if it took, I said where you could
be married to several, uh, such, uh,
several women
and also how can avow hastily made
in the heat of passion a yoke partners
for life in what donkey hotel calls.
Again,
using scholastic terminology,
we MaxCDN t irreparably meaning something
that cannot be taken back in the
Catholic church who are going to
take it back. That is how can such a,
a cow can words uttered
in this circumstances, uh,
make a marriage,
how can freewill be so easily surrendered?
The council of Trent proclaim
that the Church of horror,
clandestine marriages, an order
declared gene not to celebrate weddings.
We thought published bands
and the presence of witnesses.
This was incorporated by Phillip the
second into Spanish statutory law in 1564
and remained thus the foundation of
marriage in Spain until the 19th century.
The conflict is dealt with
very subtly in this story.
Basilio is proficient in Canon and
civil law and he puts it to good use.
In trick to Merrick Italia.
How does he do that? Well,
he threatens to die without confession.
You have to have to underline this
because, uh, even if you are a Catholic,
this is very difficult to conceive
from are a modern perspective.
So you want to die without confession.
So what,
go ahead be my guest,
but bought by threatening to do that.
Uh,
he is accusing them of,
uh,
sending him irrevocably to hell
because suicide is a mortal sin.
And uh, and uh, uh, if he
dies without confession, uh,
in the conventional side, he's
going to hell no matter what. Uh,
this is how he convinced everyone.
He is very,
he knows canon law and he knows civil law.
Uh,
so you die without confession.
If she will not give in,
Eh,
would condemn him to eternal
damnation. Keith, Daddy,
I'm the others would have done
more harm to him this way.
Then murdering him,
murdering him will be nothing
compared to eternal damnation.
Then he has both terrier.
I'm himself alter the
words about free consent.
That would legitimize the marriage
before church and society.
I'm sure you remember the episode in
which he insists and the proper words,
the legal words. I used a affirming, uh,
uh,
consent.
She confirms later her determination
afterwards to dispel any doubt about her
desires and make void any future claims
to dissolve the marriage that is cheap.
She confirms it afterwards. So it was
so just in the spur of the moment,
she confirms that she wants
to marry a busted you or are,
these are very carefully
constructed episodes, uh, uh,
to show, uh, basilio's a lawyerly skills.
But as I am suggesting in this story,
Sarah vantage probe deeper
into the issue of marriage, uh,
deeper than issues of the legal issues.
He goes back to the,
to marriage as a kind of
transubstantiation the tress
and dental metamorphoses
of matter, the transformation of
matter, the blending of bloods,
literally that makes the
union indivisible presumably.
Okay.
In looking at the episode
with this background in mind,
it appears that Cervantes
is favoring the clandestine,
I do that area most of articulated
while at the same time,
uh,
having her on Basilea
observe the rituals of,
by the Council of Trent. It,
it seems to be a middle course.
Uh,
the sacramental nature of marriage lurks
in the subtext of the story through the
myth of Pyramus and Thisbe.
It is a tragic story,
the myths of Pyramus and Thisbe in which
a cruel fate befalls the young lovers
because of a misinterpretation,
although it could be read as an ad
monetary tale about the recklessness of
youth.
The myth goes back to the conjunction of
love and death at the moment when love
ripens and is about to
become regenerative,
driven by desire.
The young lovers are to meet at the
tomb of knit Nina's where they die,
not killed by the lioness,
but by their own hands.
The bloody veil can be seen as an image
of the hymen rent in the act of love,
that bloody event,
uh,
the renting of the hymen that also
recalls the onset of menstruation.
That is the beginning of the
capacity for reproduction,
but also the recurrent
death of a woman's ovum.
The red of the trees. Fruit is both a
symbol of resurrection and of death,
as it recalls menstruation in,
uh, in their recurring coloring.
The Myth we reenacts the tragic human
predicament symbolized by the spilling of
blood at conception,
birth and death,
leaving open the possibility that the
law here, the parents' disapproval,
gun over comm or forestall
the fatality of the situation.
But the prohibition is also aligned
to death because it is instrumental in
bringing about the tragic ending in orbit.
The conflict appears to
resolve itself in beauty,
the gorgeous red fruit of the tree.
Instead of Antis. It goes further
by way of contrast and
comparison. We will, we will, uh,
later see how Velasquez deals,
whose class was class with
classical myth in Cervantes.
The Myth of pyramids on Tsp is
given in shards fragments with,
uh,
a faint outline like a distant memory.
It looks forward stores
Joyce, the Julissa's, uh,
where these fragments appear more than
backwards through the Middle Ages and the
renaissance where the
midst were more coherent.
I am inclined to believe however that's
Advantis had overt it's text in front of
him or that he had a prodigious memory.
For instance,
when Basilio feigns being near death,
his eyes are part of the act.
If you remember,
his eyes already turned in his head.
He's playing, he's about to die.
So he has his eyes turn his head,
which recalls the moment when this
B asks pyramids to answer, where,
uh,
I'm not going to read you
the Latin because then I'm
going to really sound like
a priest saying mass. And, uh,
but he heard the translation.
She heard the name of this B,
and he lifted his eyes with the weight
of debt heavy upon them and saw her face
and closed his eyes. So
the eyes, uh, the element,
this is one of the shards that I say,
uh,
remain of the middle of my
argument. My argument, uh,
follows what I would like to call or
what I like to call an itinerary of blood
from the pregnant calf on the spit that
sanctuary sees when they arrive at the
wedding, which for tells of the
sacrificial victim, the groom,
which he replaces.
It also recalls the violence at weddings,
Romeo and Juliet being the most
famous example in western literature.
The violence,
the blood announced just station and the
spilling of more blood as the new human
being. Uh, the most elemental
purpose of marriage is produced.
The consumption of the animals,
the wine and the bread.
Obvious Christian symbolism to,
to consumer to consummate go
together in a wedding celebration.
As I said earlier,
they consume the world around them,
including the earth,
through the wine.
It is a form again of transubstantiation.
Transubstantiation is the,
is the word for the Eucharist when the,
when the body of Christ is transform into
blood and wine it into bread and wine
that is of transforming one substance
into another through actions that involve
both pleasure and violence.
Hunting. Butch butchering,
squashing the grapes and of
course sex basilio's intervention.
Postpones the blood could,
would have shared in Camacho's
bed substituted that for
the fake blood that he
has concealed these blood stains,
his garment,
the proxy blot suspends the real
blood would seal the marriage.
But I contend that there is another hidden
blot that forestalls the consummation
of the intended marriage
between Camacho and criteria.
And you don't have to follow me on
this or, or, or, or, or, or, uh,
be persuaded if you don't
want to put it bluntly.
I think that the is menstruating on her
wedding day in the Spanish original it
says [inaudible],
I'll go this Colo Rita [inaudible]
pass and us know we asked in component,
but Aaliyah of any data,
this was borders. Jarvis,
the ferric Italia looked a little pale
location perhaps by want of rest the
preceding night,
which bright always employed in setting
themselves off and dressing for their
wedding day.
Following this call,
Florida in the Spanish not does
not just mean Pale, a little pale,
but to have lost once color because of
an illness or a fright and components.
It means to dress up of course,
but also to recover from an illness.
Why mentioned that she's Pale?
I believe that the suggestion
is that she's menstruating,
menstruating menstruation is fraught with
all kinds of prohibitions and lower in
all cultures in hours going back all
the way through the Old Testament.
No menstruation in this case would have
been a providential blood that would
have impeded the consummation of Camacho's
marriage. Postponing the terrios hi,
menial or high menial blood and
preserving it. Pro Basillio's bed.
Keep telling us man, situation. Her
regular, which is another word of saying,
ah, menstruation in Spanish
and it means rule simply rule.
Okay.
Would it be a superior law inherent in
the blood itself and determining the
outcome of the conflict?
Marriage is seen as ordained by God,
part of the divine plan that
supersedes customer law and overrides
considerations of unequal social status.
The process of marriage is
embedded in blood itself.
In the general transformation of matter.
According to divine grace in the Bible,
man and woman will become one
flesh in marriage. You know,
it's a pagan version.
There is no salvation possible.
The lover's fusion is only achieved as
ashes in a funerary earn or in the beauty
of a mulberry tree in
bloom instead of one.
This a form of justice have been made
and there is every reason to believe that
the commingling of broads
will lead to regeneration.
Do the birth of a new human being.
This is the kind of conclusion
that we did not find in part one,
uh,
where marriages are yet to occur.
Accepting the tale about foolish curiosity
where there is also a great deal of
blood. If you remember,
I think that, uh, uh, uh,
in a deep sense said, Ron,
this is true to, of it.
And to the spirit of metamorphosis,
Metta movement more the change of form,
what has given you the Christian twist
and translated into the present and
Cervantes.
The Myth is not retold with the
didactic Sateri call or even a,
or even aesthetic purpose. In fact,
it is not so much retold as we cycled.
It is not an Ovi Morley z.
Well read more highly say
we're Joyce from 1340.
There's a, there's a book
by in French, by Pierre,
which influenced the many, uh, writers,
including Chaucer and into which 15
bookstore or chapters of the metamorphosis
are turning into allegories.
As I mentioned before,
Maura allegories here,
this is not, uh, uh,
what sort of anthis does at all,
either on the level of,
uh,
of marriage as a social institution and
so forth or at that deeper level that
I'm claiming, uh, uh, is
total in this, in this,
in this a sob story or subtext that
I called the itinerary of blog.
Now, in this use of myth, Cervantes, uh,
resembles Velasquez.
Um,
so let us turn to Velasquez again.
And uh,
now we have to, uh, uh,
doubts the lights or uh,
but put the curtains down on,
uh,
Elaina is going to be good enough to be
showing us some paintings by Velazquez
that I used to want to
discuss in this context.
So if you wait a minute for the theatrical
part of the presentation today to be
prepared, I said, wow. All
the way down, all the way now.
Well where they are, he cannot go all the
way down, but okay, that's good enough.
And then
we turn off the lights and I got to let
my eyes adjust so that I can read my
nuts.
Let's go to the [inaudible].
Okay.
The Spanish philosopher, Jose Ortega,
Iga sit who might have mentioned before,
but I think that, uh, I want you
to remember him as part of it.
Can you see from this side?
No.
Okay.
Mentioned him before.
He's the most important Spanish
philosopher of the 20th century,
known in this country,
mostly for his book,
the Revolution of the
masses, but also, uh,
he also should be read for many books,
but one is the, the dehumanization of art,
which is about the avant garde art. In
any case, the Spanish philosopher Ortega,
uh,
claim that what Velasquez
meant by mixing classical gods.
We don't savory or ordinary characters
from everyday reality is that there are
no gods.
I'm not dressing dental.
Meaning if we take the gods to be the
representation of the higher sense of
things when seen in
connection to each other,
Velasquez, he says, is,
I caught now or Tayga,
an atheistic giant
at colossal in pills.
Man with his brush,
he banishes the gods as if
smacking them with a broom.
I love the signally because you can
think of the brush as a little broom as a
smacking them with a broom in his
back or now, which is this painting
known in Spanish as Los Barrachos.
The drunks in his back.
I know that is not only no backers,
but a rascal impersonating backers.
Yeah.
Baca now has nine figures,
two of which seem to be dressed or rather
Andress for a backing out and backing
out back on us or feasts
in honor of backers.
The God of wine celebrated
in the spring. And, and for,
uh,
these two guys who are near naked.
The others are lusty peasants,
roughly closed in contemporary dress.
And with the same sort of casual,
not post air that characterized
the naturalistic genre
scenes call in Spain bore
the bonus,
which is simply still lives in
English and Spanish are called bull.
They go on this,
these paintings sought and achieve the
effect of a casually chosen slice of
life.
But Baca Nile is carefully composed
around the light flesh of the Bogles.
Backhoes at the center,
Jonathan Brown says,
is one of the great experts on Velasquez.
He wrote a book with Elliot.
Oh, on Spanish architecture,
uh,
that attempts to interpret the painting
quote as a parody of the Olympian gods
or what's a sermon on the
evils of drink have failed.
And instead Velasquez intended
to represent backhoes as
a giver of the gift of
Wine,
which freed man temporarily from the
harsh unforgiving struggle of daily life.
Deprived of the benefits in liquid,
the bigger fines,
no respite from the which in sober
moments will be shared by all the company.
This marvelous painting hangs
or the Prado Museum and a,
if you remember the worst by
Auerbach about the supple plastic,
uh, nature of set Avantis is
art of the he's depiction of,
of of things.
I don't have an of sensuous.
And you can see that there is,
besides the connection I'm trying
to establish here, uh, uh, uh,
a kingship between Sylvana. This is
art and that of a, of [inaudible].
And you can imagine these characters
as appearing in episodes of the guilty.
I'm sure. Look at this, uh, the,
the face of stupor on this
drunk, he has sort of, uh,
uh, green, uh,
of stupidity and uh, and drunkenness
and the others, you know.
Okay.
This spinners last Elan Dennis
was painted around 1657.
It is, does a very, uh,
late work,
contemporaneous with Las Meninas and
nearly as complex and as ambitious in it
will ask us as combined two subjects,
one from the classical mythology,
um,
and the other from his own time.
It is a commonplace work
seen as you can see.
Yeah.
There are in fact two stories
from classical mythology
combined in the picture,
the fable of our acne and the
story of Jupiter's rape of Europa.
In the foreground we have
the activities of tape,
tapestry manufacturing as was done in
the factories on the royal patronage in
Madrid and in the alcove in the back.
The classical tale of the weaver Arachni.
Okay.
The scene takes place at a rock in a
shop where as a great artist just visited
by elegant ladies,
the tapestry hanging on the
back wall of the alcove,
which is presumably an agonist work is
the key to the relationship between the
two, uh, scenes. It is a woven,
a copy of Titian's the rape of Europa.
Could you give me that painting?
Yes.
This is the actual painting by
Titian, uh, the rape of Europa,
which back to England Datas,
which we find in the back.
Oops.
In that tapestry,
the rape of Europa is one of the most
celebrated of Jupiter's erotic adventures
with, with mortal women. I,
Rodney has challenged me nerve,
a patroness of weavers and goddess
of wisdom do a winning contest.
It was called a drawl,
but because her Agnes tapestry was
judged to be the equal of Minerva's and
further because it depicted such
as candles act by her father,
the God has punished Arachni
by turning her into a spider.
The story is also drawing from Ovid's
metamorphoses book four, book six.
I'm sorry. This is the reason we never
really shown just during angrily.
Okay.
Jonathan Brown again,
believes that quote by inserting
a quotation from this famous work,
the rape of Europa into the composition
Velasquez implies his belief in the
nobility and trust in dental value of
the art of painting in the spinners will
ask us six to reconcile the artificial
world of myth with a palpable world world
of visual reality without sacrificing
the decorum required for bye bye you the
one and the various militude by the
other that the courtroom by the classical
myth and the various humility,
the realism by the other,
the contrast he goes on
between the foreground,
whereas 30 women toil,
burdensome tasks and the refined
atmosphere of the artists out the year.
The scene in the back is
perhaps we Alaska's way of
implying is conviction about
the distinction between craft
and art. Well, this is fine. Uh,
that's the end of the quote by John
Brown, uh, on, at the time, uh,
there was a raging dispute as to
whether painters were artists or mere
acquiescence. This may seem a
strange to us, but there was,
yeah,
I don't, of course, Titian had
been a favorite painter of jobs.
The fifth reveal sanctuary
and Phillip the second.
So the painting is an homage to him and
there is no doubt though by inserting
Titian's painting into his Velasquez,
he's putting himself at the same level.
Well, there is a lot more to it.
It seems to me as enough Meninas.
There seems to be a revelation of the
art of the act over testic creation,
which in the painting has to
do with Minerva and Arachni.
But that taking the whole work, uh, in,
in into consideration has to do
with Velasquez. His own creation.
Creation appears as a layered
process that involves the real,
this is the real either because art is
a reflection of reality or because art
illuminates reality,
but also because reality on
veils the artificiality of art
in the spinners,
we have paintings within paintings
and the presence of in the foreground,
uh, on depressant. This is
the present in the foreground,
uh,
appears as a repetition of the
classical past. But he said,
but it is a repetition
that is also a calm down.
Can the present day spinners
recall the myth of Arachni?
It seems to me that what Velasquez
is doing as sort of take,
I said suggested about the backer.
Now is it this diminishing
the gods and also showing,
uh, by showing me Nineveh's
studio within the weaving shop,
he showing the inner
recesses of representation.
It's back day stage tricks.
Uh,
I said where I see did I
see showed in Las Meninas
the whole painting is a disingenuous in
other words is what I'm trying to say.
What we take to be gods are like today's
the spinners that weavers shop is no
different from Minerva studio in both
the deception of art are created to
deceive man.
We see the contemporary
weavers in relation to the
classical fable and we see at
the center of Alaska suspending
painting a quotation from a masterpiece.
It is again an infinitely
receding Seaquist.
It played of mirrors within this workshop
of representation that we are being
given here, which is like giving
us a worst, a workshop of Engonnia.
Therefore,
by giving us the workshop is giving us,
it is a desk in Gunyah.
Now
the process is similar
to what's the advantage
does in commercials wording
episode and how the whole of
the Keyhole, uh, an an an an an
of the whole of the chaotic, uh,
dealing with myth.
They favor of pyramids and things
we takes place in fabulous Babylon.
Got Mattress wedding takes place in
an insignificant village in Spain.
What about senior dogs is to use the
artist artistry of the fable to receive
those in attendance,
particularly Camacho on his friends,
but also the Quixote Saint John,
even the reader who does not know what
is happening until the moment that the
trick is revealed to bring the story
to a climax and eventual resolution.
There is a mirroring,
mirroring of myth and pressing reality
and the elaboration of a deceit through
artistry, acting, playing
the role of the mythological,
playing the role of a mythological
pyramids on the, uh, Basillio pain,
that role acting it out.
It is both an in Ganja on Edison
Gagnon making up the whole story.
The backstage of representation
is displayed as in Las
Meninas and as we shall
soon see in the episode
involving master bedroom,
he ness the buzz Avanti as puppeteer
and most revealingly in the culminating
episode in the whole
of the, the, the, the,
the one about Montesinos
cave in which we are,
which we are given the whole underpinning
of donkey halters madness is actual
subconscious now,
whereas in part once Cervantes seems to
be addressing the romances of chivalry
and the picaresque as models and sources.
In part two,
he takes up the grand tradition of
homer offered virtual and Dante,
particularly in episodes.
So just the Cave of Montesinos
and the pageant in the forest.
The more we'll be seeing soon,
this is very significant.
It seems to me that he now knows that
he is in their league and that he has
created a literary character that
will endure like theirs and like the
characters in classical mythology.